Новини дня «heute» з Мітрі Зіріним.
Усім доброго вечора.
Чи повинні жінки у
футболі заробляти так само як чоловіки?
Про це сьогодні Крістін розповість у новинах спорту.
Так, теза - «рівноправність», за 15 хвилин. Доброго вечора.
Ось теми цього вівторка:
правила щодо коронавірусу на осінь:
уряд Німеччини зробив пропозиції,
але федеральні землі вимагають поправок.
Обшук у Дональда Трампа: ФБР обшукує маєток
експрезидента у Флориді,
ймовірно, через документи, які він взяв із Білого дому.
Однакова платня за однакову працю - цього вимагає
канцлер Німеччини від Німецького футбольного союзу.
Після своєї феєричної гри на ЧЄ футболістки не мають
заробляти менше за футболістів, як це було дотепер.
Кілька годин тому відбулася
онлайн-конференція міністрів охорони здоров'я
як державного рівня, так і рівня федеральних земель.
Зрештою, поряд із війною та енергетичною кризою
все ще є і пандемія, яка за кілька місяців
може знову спричинити нам багато клопотів.
На осінь уряд Німеччини
представив такий план:
Маски залишаються обов'язковими
в поїздах далекого прямування та літаках.
Також обов'язковими будуть носіння масок і тестування в лікарнях
та будинках для літніх людей.
Кожна федеральна земля може розширити вимоги щодо масок,
зробивши їх обов'язковими, наприклад,
у громадському транспорті, школах чи сфері гастрономії.
Як стало зрозуміло сьогодні,
федеральні землі не в захваті від цього законопроєкту,
а щодо теми вакцинації вони навіть неабияк обурені.
Далі - Брітта Шпікерман.
Кому восени можна буде всередину, а кому - ні?
Федеральні землі зможуть самостійно
запроваджувати обов'язкове носіння масок
у закритих приміщеннях, яке не стосуватиметься лише тих,
у кого є тест, хто нещодавно перехворів
або вакцинувався не раніше, ніж три місяці тому.
Є потреба у додатковому обговоренні
представленого законопроєкту на позачерговій конференції.
Це означає, що є багато прогалин та розчарувань,
але також наявна хороша основа.
Є неабияке бажання досягнути ясності
у цій поліфонії.
Постійна комісія з вакцинації STIKO рекомендує,
після консультації з сімейним лікарем,
робити бустерне щеплення людям віком від 70 років,
а Європейське агентство з лікарських засобів - від 60.
Із цього людям має бути все зрозуміло.
Це вже третій рік пандемії.
Міністри та міністерки охорони здоров'я
висловлюють побажання,
щоб передусім розробили правила, які будуть зрозумілі для всіх.
Лаутербах розробив цей законопроєкт
разом із міністром юстиції від партії FDP Бушманом,
але багато лібералів незадоволені своїм міністром.
А як щодо Карла Лаутербаха?
Він знову порекомендував четверте щеплення принципово усім.
STIKO з цим не погоджується і досі сердиться,
про що свідчать слова професора фон Кріса, члена комісії:
«Було б краще, якби Лаутербах тримав свого язика за зубами»
Опір зростає.
І не лише в STIKO.
Якщо сказати людям, що сертифікат про вакцинацію
дійсний лише три місяці,
то це для них свідчитиме про те,
що вакцина діє лише протягом трьох місяців,
але це неправда. Вона діє набагато довше.
Тому я вважаю проблематичним навіть лише введення такого правила.
У вересні Бундестаґ має прийняти новий Закон про захист від інфекцій.
А тим часом точаться політичні та наукові суперечки.
Злість та плутанина переважають.
А про те, якою може бути кількість заражень восени,
наші онлайн-колеги поговорили
із прогнозистом у питаннях коронавірусу.
Читайте про це в нашому застосунку «ZDFheute».
Сьогодні набув чинності план ЄС на випадок
надзвичайної ситуації щодо газу,
спрямований на підготовку
до можливого припинення поставок газу з Росії.
Він передбачає добровільні заощадження газу обсягом 15%.
Голова Федерального мережевого агентства Мюллер
у ефірі ZDF закликав заощаджувати навіть 20%.
Разом із заощадженнями у всьому ЄС це може посприяти тому,
що ми матимемо достатньо газу,
щоб щасливо пережити осінь і зиму.
Тепер щодо війни в Україні.
США анонсували наступну військову допомогу
на суму 1 мільярд доларів. Сюди входять боєприпаси
та протитанкові ракети.
В Україні не припиняються бої
на півдні та на сході країни.
Наша репортерка Анне Брюль зі своєю командою
побувала на лінії фронту під Херсоном.
Вони воюють зброєю, якій 80 років.
Ми неподалік лінії фронту під Херсоном.
Українські солдати
взяли нас із собою на одну зі своїх позицій.
Нам потрібно якомога більше зброї якнайшвидше,
щоб ми змогли швидко завершити цю війну.
Хочу наголосити, що Україна сьогодні
не лише охороняє свою територію, жінок та дітей,
але й захищає всю Європу.
Ці окопи вирили росіяни,
а українці лише відвоювали цю територію.
Солдати називають нам лише свої бойові позивні.
Зараз вони саме відпочивають від атак,
які знову і знову завдають лиха селам неподалік.
Дні чотири тому росіяни так збожеволіли,
що обстріляли село касетними бомбами.
У прифронтовій зоні ми зустрічаємо подружжя,
яке живе прямо в зоні бойових дій.
Вони увесь час стріляють - і вдень, і вночі. Усім, що мають.
Нормально.
Кожну таку зустріч організовують українські бійці.
Вони з гордістю показують нам знищену російську військову техніку.
«Z» тут добре видно.
Протягом останніх тижнів
Україна повідомляє про успіхи на південному фронті.
Повідомляють про звільнення 50 сіл,
які перебували в руках російських військових.
Провести незалежну перевірку цих даних неможливо.
Вдалині ми знову і знову чуємо звуки артилерії
та бачимо на горизонті удари ракет.
Боротьба на південному фронті, ймовірно, переходить у вирішальну фазу.
За даними Агентства ООН у справах біженців,
від цієї війни з України втекло понад десять мільйонів людей.
Відтоді в Німеччині державні установи
зареєстрували майже мільйон біженців з України.
Ті, що не їхали далі або не поверталися додому,
здебільшого залишались у великих
містах, як-от Ганновер, Дортмунд чи Берлін.
До Берліна навіть зараз кожного дня прибувають сотні людей,
що поступово призводить до проблем із забезпеченням їх житлом.
Зі столиці - Ліза Янді.
Знову виникла потреба в житлових контейнерах
у колишньому аеропорту «Темпельгоф».
Довгий час вони стояли порожні,
а тепер тут живуть передусім люди з України.
Наталія з Одеси
ділить кімнату з жінкою із Києва.
Ми різні і чужі люди,
ще й собака.
У нас немає вибору, нам треба десь жити,
але іноді виникають проблеми.
Це контейнерне містечко є одним із місць розміщення людей,
які Берлін знову відкрив, щоб забезпечити житлом
шукачів притулку та біженців з України.
Наразі в нас є кількасот місць,
але щодня до нас приїжджають сотні українців.
Щодня досі прибуває близько 700 осіб.
Не всі залишаються в Берліні,
але в тимчасовому притулку в Тегелі
вони часто перебувають довше за передбачені 48 годин.
Адже ресурси інших міст і громад Німеччини теж вичерпуються.
Проблема в тому, що ми більше не маємо доступу до ринку житла,
натомість все частіше й частіше мусимо знову задіювати спортзали
або місця для колективного проживання.
У житловому контейнері Марина та її сім'я намагаються
облаштуватися максимально по-домашньому.
Ми живемо одним днем
і намагаємося створити собі затишок.
Але ми дуже хочемо знову мати власний дім.
Вони саме в пошуках квартири.
Як і багато хто в Берліні чи деінде.
Для ФБР проведення обшуків - це цілком нормально.
Але до вчорашнього вечора ще не було такого,
щоб ФБР обшукувало експрезидента.
Агенти обшукали розкішний маєток Дональда Трампа,
який сам оприлюднив інформацію про обшук
і говорив про політичні переслідування.
Трамп начебто взяв із собою
документи з Білого дому,
зміст яких загрожує національній безпеці.
З Вашингтона - Ельмар Тевесен.
Вони прийшли о 9 ранку, одягнені в цивільне.
Десяток агентів ФБР.
Увесь день вони обшукували Мар-а-Лаго,
резиденцію екс-президента у Флориді.
Уперше про обшук стало відомо із заяви Дональда Трампа,
зробленої в понеділок увечері.
Трамп називає його «непотрібним, недоречним і корумпованим».
Але ФБР діяло за дорученням Міністерства юстиції
та відповідно до постанови суду.
Підозра: Трамп викрав документи із позначкою «цілком таємно».
У такому разі необхідно перед Федеральним судом
довести обґрунтовану підозру
у вчиненні кримінального злочину.
Також треба довести наявність доказів на ймовірному місці злочину.
ФБР обшукувало цілеспрямовано,
навіть зламало сейф Дональда Трампа.
Ще в січні Національний архів вилучив тут
15 картонних коробок,
у яких було, зокрема, листування
з північнокорейським диктатором Кімом.
З огляду на ці фото можна стверджувати, що Трамп
знову зливав документи в унітаз.
Сам Трамп, будучи в понеділок у Нью-Йорку,
доручив говорити за себе своєму сину Еріку.
Білий дім, очевидно, хоче вжити заходів щодо людини,
яку він вважає найбільшою загрозою для Джо Байдена.
Як пишуть у Twitter провідні республіканці, ФБР використовують
як зброю проти політичного опонента.
Також прихильники Трампа
ще вночі зібралися перед його резиденцією.
Вони ведуть розслідування проти Трампа,
тому що бояться його кандидатури.
Вони вважають, що він знову переможе.
Якщо ФБР знайде цілком таємні державні документи,
то Трампу загрожує штраф та
позбавлення волі до трьох років.
Тепер новини з іншого континенту - з Кенії:
одна з найстабільніших африканських країн,
популярна серед туристів,
але постраждала від згубного впливу світової економіки.
Там обирають нового президента.
Кенія та її столиця Найробі
розташовані на сході Африки і перебувають у борговій кризі.
Для населення це означає:
зростання податків та, відповідно, цін.
Обидва кандидати у президенти обіцяють
покращення ситуації після виборів,
на які зареєструвалося 22 мільйони осіб.
Репортаж Сюзан фон Лоєвскі.
Вибори в Кенії розпочалися як вдосвіта.
Ще до відкриття виборчих
дільниць утворилися довгі черги.
Тут, у районі племені Масаї Каджіадо,
з нетерпінням чекають
на результати виборів.
Народ Кенії обере майбутнього лідера країни.
Лідера, який на думку виборців,
покращить економіку країни.
Ослаблена економіка країни -
це топ-тема передвиборчої кампанії.
Віцепрезидент Вільям Руто,
який балотується на пост президента,
орієнтується на соціально незахищені верстви населення.
Я впевнений,
що народ Кенії зробить правильний вибір,
який вирішить майбутнє нашої країни.
Головний конкурент Руто - досвідчений
77-річний політик Раїла Одінґа,
його дружина - віцекандидатка, провідною юристка Марта Каруа,
яка не була замішана у корупційних схемах.
Каруа - представниця найбільшої
етнічної групи кікуйю,
що гарантує велику кількість голосів.
Це перевага.
Вона б стала першою жінкою віце-президентом.
Вона покращить становище інших жінок в політиці.
Багато молодих кенійців розчаровані в політиці та
не зареєструвалися на вибори.
Наразі вибори проходять у штатному режимі.
Наскільки спокійно пройдуть вибори, залежить
головним чином від того, коли оприлюднять результати.
Країна досі не оговталася від подій 2007 року.
Тоді результати виборів було затримано,
що призвело до масових заворушень та
понад тисячі смертей.
Нині 150 000 представників служби безпеки
задіяні по всій країні для захисту демократії Кенії.
Зміни клімату уже суттєво відчутні.
З середини квітня в Німеччині
протягом тривалого періоду не було опадів.
Дослідники клімату прогнозують збільшення тривалості
періодів спеки та посухи,
які за минулі місяці стали
серйозною проблемою для людей і природи.
Який вплив це має на життя риб,
розкаже Ізабель де ла Вега.
Важкі часи для розведення форелі
в гессенському Герцберге.
Спека і посуха виснажують тварин.
Нам важко утримувати рибу.
Все це через спеку та посуху.
Бо зі струмка вгорі надходить недостатньо води.
І, відповідно, вода прогрівається набагато сильніше.
Оскільки риба не зможе пережити такі зміни,
водойми з фореллю потрібно постійно
насичувати киснем
та додатково поповнювати запаси води.
Ця риба також потребує невідкладної допомоги.
Уже сотні загинули в Аллері біля Вольфсбурга.
Рівень води падає.
Якщо кілька років тому рівень води в Рейні
в середньому сягав трьох метрів,
то зараз позначка тримається на рівні 1,47 м.
Вимірювальна станція на річці Майн.
Експерти вказують на те, що
від спеки у риби змінюється обмін речовин..
Через високу температуру води
пришвидшуються обмінні процеси.
Це призводить
до більшого споживання кисню.
Проте існують заходи
для запобігання нестачі кисню,
а саме насадження дерев на берегах водойм.
Найкраще було б терміново затінити річки.
Це те, що допоможе нам охолодити води річок
та зменшити надходження шкідливих речовин
через поверхню води та очисні споруди.
Реалізація цих заходів стає все необхіднішою
через підвищення температури.
Премія Георґа Бюхнера
вважається однією з найвизначніших літературних
відзнак у німецькомовному просторі.
Цього року її отримала авторка турецького походження
Еміне Севгі Оздамар.
Вже понад три десятиліття вона також пише німецькою:
романи, оповідання і п'єси.
На думку жюрі: німецька література завдячує їй
новими горизонтами та високопоетичним звучанням.
Зовсім інше звучання було в Олівії Ньютон-Джон.
Всесвітню славу вона здобула понад 40 років тому
завдяки мюзиклам «Бріолін» та «Ксанаду».
Співачка та актриса
померла у віці 73 років.
За нею сумують у всьому світі.
Прихильники кладуть квіти на Алеї слави.
Протягом десятиліть Ньютон-Джон до кінця боролася
проти раку грудей,
була активісткою в цій боротьбі та підтримувала
інших хворих.
Незабутньою залишається її роль Сенді
разом з Джоном Траволтою в мюзіклі «Бріолін».
Завжди на слуху. Тепер перейдемо до теми спорту.
Сьогодні канцлер
відвідав Німецький футбольний союз
і знову говорив про однаковий розмір премій, Крістін. - Так,
з цим треба щось робити. «Equal Pay». Ключові слова.
Президент футбольного союзу Бернд Нойендорф
після зустрічі з канцлером підтвердив,
що велися переговори щодо однакової зарплати
жінок і чоловіків у футболі і пояснив, що
система нарахування премій застаріла.
Канцлер на зустрічі з верхівкою футбольного союзу
наполягав на рівності жіночих та чоловічих команд.
Свої вимоги Шольц озвучив ще під час ЧЄ.
Ключовими словами «рівна оплата»
він оживив дебати.
Також канцлер виступає за рівні премії.
Я вважаю, що це сфера політики.
На відміну від переговорів про зарплату,
які ведуть успішні спортсмени.
Ось чому варто
обговорити рівні премії.
Також тренерка національної збірної Фосс-Текленбург
під час програми
das aktuelle sportstudio заявила про
відповідність премій для жіночих та чоловічих збірних.
Рівні виплати за звання чемпіона,
але , будь ласка, чоловікам трохи менше,
а нам - більше.
Я досі вважаю, що це занадто.
Тому я готовий обговорити у наших органах
доречність системи нарахування премій,
яка вибудовувалась роками.
Після ЧЄ висунуто такі вимоги:
основна заробітна плата, рівні можливості,
час прайм-тайму,
більше медійної присутності та визнання.
Сьогоднішня зустріч демонструє
прагнення до змін.
Наступний виклик для франкфуртського «Айнтрахту».
Через чотири дні після невдалого початку сезону
проти Баварії чемпіон Ліги Європи зіграє матч
за суперкубок УЄФА
з переможцем Ліги чемпіонів мадридським «Реалом».
Гра відбудеться завтра ввечері в Гельсінкі.
«Айнтрахт» має кадрові втрати.
У «Айнтрахті» сьогодні, як і в попередні дні,
тільки і мова, що про Филипа Костича.
Він був присутнім вранці на фінальному тренуванні
у Франкфурті,
проте ввечері у Гельсінкі команда вийшла
на поле вже без сербського гравця.
За даними ЗМІ 29-річний футболіст
переходить в туринський «Ювентус».
Виходить, що Филип підписує
останній контракт у своїй кар'єрі.
Це, звичайно, його рішення на майбутнє.
Що він хоче зробити, що нового хоче спробувати?
За ці чотири роки в франкфуртському «Айнтрахті»
Костич став одним з найкращих
вінгерів Бундесліги.
Без нього зіграти проти мадридського «Реала»
на Олімпійському стадіоні в Гельсінкі буде важче.
А Тімо Вернер остаточно повертається з «Челсі»
до Лейпцигу.
Дуже дякую, Крістін.
Надзвичайна засуха не відступає,
докладніше про погоду Озден Терлі за мить.
Інтерв'ю з міністром охорони здоров'я
Лаутербахом у heute journal
о 21:45 з Марієттою Сломкою.
Це були новини вівторка.
Побачимось завтра, до зустрічі, гарного вечора.
Доброго вечора, з вами погода.
Найближчими днями опадів майже не передбачається,
оскільки зона високого тиску простяглася
від Атлантичного океану до Східної Європи.
Гаряче повітря йде до нас із південного заходу.
Тому температура сягне позначки 30°C
передусім на Заході Німеччини.
Опадів не передбачається.
У Франції та Іспанії можливі опади від одного до десяти
літрів на квадратний метр, що надзвичайно мало.
В Італії трохи більше опадів:
від 10 до 70 літрів за умови сильних злив та гроз.
Погода вночі.
Без опадів, малохмарно,
туман у районі Балтійського моря.
Температура коливатиметься від 9°C в Альпах,
10°C в Північнонімецькій низовині.
До 18°C в районі річок Рейну та Майну.
Завтра ясно та малохмарно,
без опадів, температура сягатиме 32°C,
на південному Заході Німеччини або
на Нижньому Рейні.
Трохи прохолодніше на морському узбережжі - до 22°C.
У наступні кілька днів очікується
поступове підвищення температури,
у четвер - до 33°C.
У п'ятницю місцями грози на півдні,
а в суботу - на сході, температура до 35°C.
Гарного вечора!